الرئيسان الأمريكيان السابقان بيل كلينتون
ودونالد ترامب الأمير البريطاني أندرو
من بين الأسماء التي ظهرت في
الوثائق التي تم الكشف عنها حديثًا في دعوى قانونية
تتعلق بالاتجار بالجنس، الذي مات الآن
جيفري إبستين، وهو شاذ جنسيا للأطفال،
وقد تم بالفعل نشر معظم المعلومات الواردة في هذه الوثائق،
ومن المهم
ملاحظة شخص ما.  الاسم ليس
مؤشرًا على ارتكاب مخالفات، مزيد من التفاصيل
الآن من CNN Shaman
proz، المستندات الصادرة عن الحبل
تنبع من دعوى قضائية تم
رفعها في عام 2015 ضد جالين ماكسويل التي
كانت الصديقة السابقة لجيفري
إبستين، وكانت دعوى مدنية بتهمة
التشهير في النهاية  حسمت
القضية ولكن أخيرًا بعد سنوات
تم الإفراج عن المستندات وبعض
المعلومات المحددة ومهمة جدًا أه قادمة من الإفادات التي
أخذها المحامون من أحد
شركاء جيفري إبستين امرأة
كانت تعمل معه أه حيث تقول
ذلك  أخبرها جيفري إبستين أن
الرئيس السابق بيل كلينتون مثلهم
صغارًا في إشارة إلى الفتيات تقول أه وقالت
إنهم داروا محادثة حول
الرئيس السابق الآن
الرئيس السابق نفى ارتكاب أي مخالفات
ولا توجد اتهامات أه في
ملفات المحكمة بأي  نوع من المخالفات
أو أي نوع من النشاط الإجرامي من
جانب الرئيس السابق
متحدث باسم أه الرئيس السابق
قال أه طالما فعل ذلك في عام 2019 أه
أنه هناك ينفي ارتكاب أي
خطأ يعترف بوجوده على متن
طائرة جيفري إبستين  لكنه يقول أنه قد
مضى ما يقرب من 20 عامًا منذ أن كان
للرئيس السابق أي اتصال مع إبستاين
أه وبالطبع لم
يتم اتهام كلينتون بأي جرائم أو مخالفات
تتعلق بإبستين وأيضًا في نفس تلك
الإفادة من الموظف السابق أه
علمنا ذلك  تقول وفقًا أه
لشهادتها أن جيفري إبستين
كانا على متن طائرة معًا على إحدى
طائرات إبستاين متجهة إلى مدينة نيويورك
ولم يتمكنوا من الهبوط في نيويورك
ولذا كان عليهم الذهاب إلى أتلانتيك سيتي
وتقول أثناء ذلك  بالطائرة،
أخبرها جيفري إبستاين أننا سنتصل بترامب وسنذهب
إلى أتلانتيك سيتي،
وقالت إنهما انتهى بهما الأمر بالذهاب إلى كازينو، وهي
لا تتذكر أه ما هو ذلك الكازينو،
ومرة ​​أخرى تكمن أهمية هذا
في أننا  رؤيتك تعرف
اسمين لرئيسين سابقين تم ذكرهما هنا،
هذه الأسماء المذكورة ليست
بالضرورة جديدة، إنه بالتأكيد شيء أه
توقعناه والآن كما تعلم
في الأيام القادمة نتوقع
رؤية المزيد من المستندات حيث
تعمل المحكمة والمحامون على بعض الأمور  المزيد من
هذه التسجيلات وتخطط لنشر المزيد من
المعلومات أه في
الأيام المقبلة، وقد تواصل Sean Pro هناك وCNN
مع حملة ترامب للتعليق الذي
لا يزال في
انتظار